welcome to another thankful thursday i
believe it's important to thank the
people in your life in your business
who've had an impact who've helped you
you can't do this alone and it's nice to
say thank you to the people who've
helped you along on your path because i
find that uh often we forget we take
things for granted so
today i want to thank a friend of mine
bailey vaz and bailey runs a company
called proactive movement it's a
workplace wellness company here in
toronto and city
bailey's been a member of my mastermind
group for years and
one day she came to me and she said evan
you know i really love your website
and i used to love it more
you know i
used to have all these famous stories of
successful entrepreneurs and how they
got started and that inspired me and it
motivated me and now i don't get that
anymore and it's true i changed my set
around and tried to focus on the
products i was selling and some of the
other stuff i was up to
and it struck a chord because i was
growing disconnected with my website as
well you know i was spending most of my
time on my youtube videos and my
newsletter and personal projects and
neglected my site a little bit and
had been
starting to think you know i got to do
something with my side i got to do
something with the side i want people to
come
and and get that feeling of excitement
and being ready for action and being
inspired after they visit my site which
i used to have but i kind of got away
from and bailey's comment just kind of
you know it was that extra little push
you know it's something i've been
sitting with in my head for a while you
know how you have all these ideas you
got all these ideas and you want to do a
bunch of stuff and you're not sure what
to do next and that was one of them just
kind of been lingering there for a while
and her comment just kind of pushed me
over a little bit and and made that
happen my whole site got redesigned and
so bailey wanted to thank you for your
honesty you know uh for your
your courage and telling me a hard truth
it helped i had a huge impact and um
thank you for all of your
wisdom and friendship over the years
and so for all you guys watching i want
you to take some time today and thank
somebody who's had an impact on your
business okay you can make a video you
can just send them a quick email you can
write a handwritten note doesn't have to
cost you any money just just reach out
and show people that you care
that they helped you and just say thank
you it'll make you feel great it'll make
them feel great everybody's able to be
better
believe
for those who watching like the video
you can subscribe to the channel see
more videos just like this thank you so
much i'll see you soon